[Musique]
je veux qu'on se parle aujourd'hui
d'innovation qu'on se parle d'innovation
avec hop hop hop hop une entreprise qui
est extrêmement forte dans l'innovation
ils sont arrivés en france à quelques
années souvenez vous c'était au
carrousel du louvre avec le finepix
smartphone extrêmement innovant qui
venait lever la partie caméra enfin il y
avait une très très belle innovation une
très belle proposition est un très joli
smartphone ou pour continue avec de
l'innovation au niveau de sa les
batteries vous avez le système super
vous que la super vous que ces deux
batteries dans une batterie qui vous
permet de recharger rapidement avec de
la basse tension donc on ne venant pas
abîmer votre batterie au plomb contenu
toujours à innover au niveau des écrans
au niveau des smartphones enfin bref aux
poteaux entreprises qui innovent et là
ils m'ont contacté quelques jours un
ancien monsieur revendeur montrer le
prototype d'un oud smartphone d'un
nouveau genre qui n'est qu'un prototype
pour l'instant qui a priori ne va pas
arriver sur le marché en tout cas pas
tout de suite mais en tout cas ça donne
vraiment une ligne directrice et samut
là où va aller au pot ce smartphone
c'est le au po x 2021
[Musique]
souvenez-vous j'en ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup parlé avant même que les
premiers smartphones à écran pliable
surreprésentés je vous parlait déjà de
smartphones calice plier d'écran qu'à
l'esprit y est comme on a ri de soi
grandir la zone utile de son smartphone
c'est à dire vous avez votre smartphone
vous la grandissiez ou alors comment est
ce qu'on arrive à réduire l'encombrement
en revenant le plier c'était vraiment
tout l'intérêt et la limite un peu du
système est bien c'est que quand on plie
forcément on a une marque on plie comme
une feuille vous pourrez y jouer à plier
ou bien vous avez marre de la figure
c'est normal c'est la physique du coup
au pouvoir réfléchissant tiens comment
est-ce que nous pourrait augmenter la
surface de nos smartphones sans pour
autant venir plié très intéressant est
il sorti dans la même direction que là
où est partie lg il ya trois ans trois
ans c'est vrai ce que tu nous montrait
c'est un proto l'époque c'était leur
télé enroulable alors s'était pas autant
métissé d'être début 2018 qu'on a vu
cette télé enroulable s'est faite dans
un espèce de caissons la télé sortez et
elles redescendent l'année d'après lg a
officialisé ce produit pour donc
l'acheter il est commercialisé très cher
donc l'idée de la dalle oled puisqu'on
parle bien ici de oled qu'on peut venir
plier pas du lcd uniquement dû aux led
et bien au pot a intégré en tout cas
l'idée le ce fonctionnement dans son
smartphone
ici on est sur l'écran de 6,7 pouces
fermé donc ça nous fait un grand
smartphone lorsque vous allez venir
actionner le smartphone soit en double
tapant sur le bouton soit en faisant un
petit slide surcoté et bien le
smartphone va s'agrandir pour arriver un
écran de cette taille 4 pouces et ça
c'est vachement intéressant c'est super
intéressante puisque en fait on va venir
augmenter la taille de son smartphone
sans pour autant vous d'un pli donc sans
aucune marque sans aucune sensation de
pli sous le doigt et en ayant ce système
où l'écran va venir tourner à
l'intérieur alors en fait le truc
intéressant à comprendre c'est que votre
écran il vient se loger au dos de votre
smartphone il vient donc faire un tour
grâce à un mécanisme et ils ne sont
roule pas sur lui même comme sur un
petit cigare il ne se plie pas il vient
en fait que se cachait et ça c'est
vachement intéressant et je n'avais pas
imaginé comme ça au final on va se dire
qu'est ce qu'un ordinateur
tout ça est ce que c'est réellement
intéressant est ce que c'est réellement
pertinent pour un coût écoutez tout ça
pas mal tout ça pas mal le premier
avantage ce qui est différent par
rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver
ailleurs notamment chez huawei avec son
mec xs notamment avec samsung action
l'axis êtes folle deux là où les autres
smartphones ont une taille fermé et une
taille ouverte là vous allez pouvoir
venir l'ouvrir comme vous souhaitez en
fonction de l'application vous allez
pouvoir revenir osciller entre hugo de 6
7 pouces minimum et une diagonale simone
de 7 4 pouces peut vous arrêter entre
les deux pourront pas faire 7 pouces 7,1
7,2 un 6.968 wever ce que vous voulez ça
permettra donc de laisser le champ libre
aux programmateurs ont développeurs
d'applications pour utiliser la partie
utile dont ils ont besoin pour leurs
applications
ça peut donc permettre des expériences
complètement personnalisé différentes et
s'ouvrira de la manière dont il le
souhaitera donc voyez ça c'est super et
enfin parce que si vous regardez ce
qu'on retrouve parole prêchée pas chez
samsung avec le galaxy z paul ii 2 eh
bien vous avez une taille ferney avec
votre écran extérieur une taille ouverte
à l'intérieur ce qui est super mais vous
n'avez pas cette modularité de taille
d'écran ce que nous permet d'avoir cette
technologie que propose aujourd'hui au
pot sur son prototype ce n'est qu'un
prototype une fois de plus il n'est pas
commercialisé il n'a pas de valeur
marchande vient pas de prix d'ailleurs
s'il avait un prix à mon avis ça sera
quand même relativement cher on est donc
en mesure lundi scission entre auto on
n'est pas sur un produit fini on a donc
pas de caméra à l'avant à l'arrière
c'est somme toute assez sommaire on a
pas de bouton sur le côté si ce n'est le
petit bouton qui nous permet de veiller
en ouvrir et les fermer ici on n'est pas
sur un produit fini qu'on va me dire
commercialisé on est vraiment sur une
idée et voir comment est ce qu'on arrive
à intégrer cette technologie dans un
smartphone il faut savoir que ce proto
avait été présenté l'année dernière
en asie c'est la première fois qu'il
arrive en france c'est une super
nouvelle parce que ça permet à au pot
c'est de continuer à se positionner
comme étant leader en matière
d'innovation aujourd'hui au pot en
france tu marques et encore pas assez
connu c'est une marque est très jeune
c'est une marque qu'on peut voir
notamment dans le sport notamment dans
le tennis sur le côté des courts de
tennis à roland-garros mais maintenant
c'est une marque qui est extrêmement
intéressante de très très belles
innovations au niveau des smartphones au
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils viennent vous
montrer un prototype que vous ne pourrez
pas acheter et qui ne sera probablement
pas disponible dans le commerce que
cette technologie disputent le commerce
avant quelques bons mois voire années
et bien tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
besoin
de montrer qu'ils sont forts qui sont
forts en termes d'innovation qui vont
fortement d'une technologie
j'imagine qu'ils ont aussi d'autres
produits dans les tuyaux notamment
pourquoi pas les smartphones piège enfin
voilà ça c'est super intéressant et
surtout il nous montre une façon de
venir agrandir la surface utile de son
smartphone que pour l'instant pour
l'instant aucune autre marque nous avait
montré de cette manière là je sais pas
comment vous le verriez ou en termes
d'usagé est-ce que ça c'est vraiment
intéressant parce qu'il faut toujours
penser il ajoute on nous demande des
techno à son super sexy faut vraiment se
projeter derrière sur l'utilisation est
ce que je viendrais utiliser un
smartphone avec un écran qui va venir
bouger un petit peu comme ça une fois de
plus ça va dépendre pourront proposer
les développeurs derrière tout ça peut
déjà montré c'était que par exemple
parce que vous êtes dans les paramètres
de votre smartphone etc renfermé vous
naviguez un peu classiquement il lorsque
vous l'ouvrez lié au fait apparaître un
petit menu sur un côté qui vous permet
de switcher entre les différentes
parties claude point c'est toujours un
peu la question de la fragilité alors
bien évidemment au pot nous annoncent
que leur système on peut l'ouvrir et le
fermer plus de cent mille fois sans
problème mais qu'est ce que c'est les
yeux les histoires qu'on vous raconte
peut-être de toute façon je ne pas les
ouvrir et les fermer
sambi une fois pour le vérifier ce qu'on
voit ce que son côté quand même des
petits sera zone du glissières des
petites zones où j'aurais peur que des
impuretés viennent passer alors
j'imagine que s'ils ce prototype était
un modèle fini prêt à être vendu sur le
marché
eh bien on se retrouverait avec un
système qui réplique très peut-être
davantage la poussière jeune jim classe
et déjà le câble pour moi c'est sûr très
très important et vous savez que de
toute façon un produit comme celui-là
c'est un produit qui ne peut pas être
certifié actuellement il ya des normes
pour qu'un projet soit certifié
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière il
est évident que ces produits là comme on
porterait notamment chez samsung avec
son galaxy z folle de 2 comme on
retrouve également chez huawei bien ça
ne certifie pas puisqu'on est en dehors
de toute norme de certification
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça ne
certifie pas ça ne veut pas dire
néanmoins que ces premiers tours pas
étanche donc je trouve que l'idée est
intéressante le concept est séduisant
ça permet de voir de quelle manière un
constructeur comme mon pot et peut-être
d'autres plus tard en tout cas viennent
innover pour proposer de nouvelles
alternatives pour agrandir la surface
utile de son smartphone l'écran ce qui
est sûr et qui est vraiment cool c'est
que en 2021
on va continuer à être surpris au niveau
de l'innovation dans le monde des
smartphones que ce soit chez au pot ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs on en parle de ce
produit dans le podcast vous invite à
venir le retrouver bien le lien que vous
avez en bas dans la description et sera
disponible d'ici
24 heures le temps que je mette en ligne
aller le consulter c'est intéressant
d'après encore plus de choses sur repos
encore plus de choses justement sur ce
smartphone le hautboïste 2021 on
comprend beaucoup plus de choses on a eu
une longue interview je crois c'est une
peu plus de 20 minutes c'est vraiment
très très cool allez y jeter une oreille
et bien évidemment vous abonner au
podcast fréquence dreux sur ce dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez
quels usages vous verriez derrière cette
nouvelle technologie qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous pourriez en faire que ça
pourrait vous intéresser si un
smartphone comme celui là avec cet écran
qui s'agrandissait sans venir piller son
pays ressent rien était sur le marché
est ce que vous pourriez lâcheté oui ou
non
mark et moi ça en bas en commentaire me
retrouve très vite des bisous du
chocolat et des gros cap au total